we are living through one of the most
interesting unique and scary times in
recent human history and with a global
pandemic with upheaval in upheaval in
global economics no matter who you are
whether you're a content creator an
entrepreneur someone who's looking to
reinvent themselves this is crazy times
and I felt it was so important to do a
video really talking about how we can do
strategic planning even in the midst of
crisis I mean here are the facts friends
right now we are seeing that the u.s. is
nowhere close to reopening the economy
is what the New York Times is saying the
Japan economy recently has released one
trillion dollars in a relief plan and
right now 29% of the US economy is
actually frozen by the corona virus
outbreak so I'm actually curious let me
know in the comments how this has
affected you have you found yourself in
any kind of job upheaval have you been
laid off or maybe this is kind of stupid
business as usual maybe quarantined let
me know and in this stream I'm gonna be
breaking down ten strategic questions
that we can be asking to actually
position ourselves during this time even
in the midst of a lot of uncertainty
that are really gonna help you get an
edge so that you can protect your
business make money on the side and
really continue to make a greater impact
even in the midst of all this craziness
that we're living through but if we are
just meeting right now my name is Sean
kennel this channel think marketing is
devoted to helping you really learn
modern marketing how do you market
yourself build a personal brand market
your business with YouTube with online
video I'm the co-author of the book
YouTube secrets and the founder of think
media our main channel where we talk a
lot about tech and tools and live
streaming and things like that but today
our topic is all about strategic
planning for content creators and ten
questions to help you grow online right
now if you want this is gonna be more of
a strategic training and I think that
writing down these questions grab a
journal grab something to write with
this will really help you get an edge
as a content creator whether you're
already established or whether you're
finding that in this era you're thinking
about man now's the time that I need to
start creating content on YouTube live
streaming and really adapting to these
times or maybe you're a business owner
and you're also recognizing shoot my
business is being disrupted more than
ever before I need to be creating
content not just to stay connected with
my customers and potential prospects but
I also need to be creating content just
for relevancy in to stay top of mind and
potentially move my business online and
here's some if you will encouraging
stats and some good news right now
Nielsen says that content consumption
will rise 60% during this isolation
check this out search marketing Daley
says that desktop search is going up
because people are they have
shelter-in-place mandates there's been a
massive increase in google search and a
lot more people are actually searching
from their desktops and so this is so
powerful because remember YouTube is a
search engine it's the second largest
search engine in the world so you need
to be creating relevant content that's
answering specific questions even as
more people by the way Mobile's up as
well but more people are actually at
home leaning into content more leaning
into online cotton more and 66% of
social media consumers expect their
social media consumption to rise during
this time and so before we get into
these 10 tips here's like the thesis you
need to be going all-in with creating
content right now creators create like
you got to be doubling down tripling
down and getting crazy with content
creation listen to these stats from
Yahoo Finance 66% of social media users
believe that their social media is going
up and let me know in the comments like
have you noticed your screen times going
up I know mine has have you been
scrolling more spending more time on
social 64 percent expect their YouTube
usage to increase 63% their Facebook to
increase and listen to this about
e-commerce 99
cent believe that there is a chance that
they're gonna purchase something online
if they're confined to their home like
99 out of 100 people are like yeah I'm
shopping online now guess what that is a
massive shift because people are like yo
I can just go to the store that is
completely been disrupted so ecommerce
affiliate marketing online shopping this
is your time creators create you gotta
be going all in with creating content
people in the survey said that a great
deal of them would buy groceries online
which by the way there's affiliate
marketing for that a lot of people have
said that they would buy DIY in
home-improvement item items online 80%
of people and then of course 76% of
people said that they would do at home
delivery services and so the bottom line
is this friends now is the time to be
leaning in as a content creator but we
got a plan if you fail to plan you plan
to fail and I've got 10 specific
questions that are broken into four
areas that has content creators we
really need to lean in on now if you are
here on the live stream I've got the
think team helping me they'll be
answering your questions
good to see you Brandon Lee cook they'll
drop you a link if you ever want to know
about our gear you could go to think
media tools dot-com and they will help
you out with the tools that that's where
a list of our software and our gear that
we use and this is also a follow up to a
recent training that I did where I said
I would add more value so if you didn't
see the recent web class I did a really
about adapting pivoting and thriving
during these times that's that idea to
income dot tips and for a little while
longer depending on when you're watching
this or catching it on the replay we
have this class that really talks about
when I went through a personal pandemic
and lost 90% of my income in 2015 and
what exactly what I did to adapt to that
time I'm also gonna be doing Q&A with
you as well and so um if you've got some
questions throw up for question marks
before and after and I will hit those at
the end of this training as many as I
could get to but we're talking about 10
tips for a really strategic plan
and these are actually questions that we
need to be asking as content creators
and so here's the first category all
right write this down number one you got
to clarify your path to making money
right now
if you want to work from home if you are
a content creator that is growing your
influence but you haven't started
generating money or you're just starting
from scratch and you're ready to start
generating money on your own terms and
trying to figure out how to reinvent
yourself maybe move your business online
the first area that you have to clarify
if you're gonna make a strategic plan
Shawn how do you know it's gonna happen
in the future I don't how long are we
gonna be locked down stay at home orders
no idea there's a lot of things that we
can't control so what can we control as
content creators the first thing you
need to clarify is your your your path
to making money in this circumstance a
lot of people in our community people
aren't buying homes they're not leaving
their homes really and so what do i do
as a real estate agent you clarify what
you can do right now and so here's the
first couple questions in the first
category
what is your shortest path to income
like as a content creator this is I
think the very first question you should
ask I am all for getting crazy and going
all-in on YouTube right now to build
your influence but here's the deal
YouTube is a marathon and not a sprint
one of our students dr. iHealth who's a
part of video ranking Academy and inner
circle he's making like five six
thousand a month right now he's been
around our community and in our programs
for about 16 months he started from
scratch he didn't even need never been
on camera and had never shot a video in
his life but did you hear me it took
about 16 months it's not the shortest
path to be thinking about like YouTube
Adsense affiliate marketing the shortest
path is what can you do to get money now
and you got to take care of your family
now tell me and we have a lot of smart
people here are you still working are
you still you know in your job you know
in your your typical job and if you
aren't maybe you've been laid off maybe
something has happened then you have to
be pivoting right now to be thinking how
can I pay the bills essentially
even from home a day job while I'm
building my dream job right and so you
know TMA is talking about how I have a
Travel Channel but it's difficult to
come out up with ideas because I'm not
traveling right now so it's a good point
you've got this online brand but you got
to be thinking about what am i doing
today right now while maybe that's on
hold hey we're gonna travel again we're
gonna see the economy shift again I'm
saying as a content creator blinders on
what can you do right now and what is
your shortest path to making money
online Shari I'm a teacher and we're
gearing up to do some teaching online I
love that and and now that's one of the
big opportunities right now because so
much teaching is getting moved online
henry has been furloughed so Henry maybe
you can't control that but what can you
control so what's your shortest path to
making income couple resources for you
Fox Business just released companies
hiring work from home jobs during
coronavirus companies like Adobe Dell
williams-sonoma and so we'll put a link
to that article but that's one thing to
consider this might be how am I going to
get money now again as a content creator
I think there's something about being
practical and then while you're also
working on the dream and then if you
haven't seen this we'll link that up as
well we did 15 high-paying online jobs
you could do from home there's side
hustle I D --is that I did with my
friend Angie Lee that's on our other
channel so those are a couple resources
but question number one is what's your
shortest path to making income but
here's the second question
what is your smartest path to making
income okay so what's your smartest path
shortest path you got to do the
practical today shoot you might be
flipping stuff on Facebook marketplace
eBay looking at stuff from around your
house you know I don't know you maybe
not supposed to see people but you're
jumping on and doing Craigslist and you
know keeping six feet different setting
it on on the curb and saying alright you
give me the same time man same time I
don't know you you know like whatever
and in figuring out your shortest path
but then your smartest path what do I
mean by that what are you doing right
now
this is for you the content creator the
aspiring content creator to set yourself
up for the future you know
the truth is the smartest time to really
start building your influence on YouTube
the smartest time to start building a
personal brand when is the best time to
plant a tree five years ago well when's
the second best time to plant a tree
today creators create friends and
content consumptions going up like crazy
the smartest path is you better be going
all-in right now on creating content
strategic content and thinking about
what is it you're doing to set yourself
up now for the future you know on that
web class that I did that's available
for a little bit while longer in 2009
this is not new to me you know obviously
this is kind of a new situation and
there's tons of different nuances but my
wife and I we already got crushed in a
massive economic recession we lost a
rental property at the time my wife's
health it was like the perfect storm she
got hospitalized she almost died you
know we were losing jobs losing money
and the economy completely collapsed
back in 2008-2009 so we lived through
that that was what birthed Who I am and
where I am today so what I'm telling you
as a content creator
what's your smartest path to making
income you got to be leveraging and
positioning and being strategic with
right now to set yourself up to for the
future and so that is the first two
questions and it's the first category
clarify your path to making money write
this stuff down
what am I going to do in the short term
to get income and then what am I gonna
do as far as the smartest path because
by the way in three to six months you
could be making really good money online
but it might take three to six months so
you need that lifeline for maybe the
next you know a couple weeks next couple
months and so be thinking about that and
check out those resources that will link
up as well including the side hustle
ideas and things like that category
number two and if you're getting like
value out of this video can you smash
the like button and maybe tag somebody
or share this with somebody who maybe is
for a load or maybe is going through
something right now cuz I really believe
this information will
them level up and adapt and pivot to
this time second category though after
you clarify your shortest path or
clarify your path to revenue you need to
clarify the skills you need for the
future clarify the skills you need for
the future so what skill knowledge or
expertise next question can you use
right now to make money online let me
know and tell me that in the comments
what skill what knowledge what expertise
in the side household video we talked
about tutoring if you know English it
helps if you have an MBA you can jump
and start doing tutoring over zoom if
you do graphic design can you actually
start selling that skill and up work
right right now if you're a video editor
can you start selling that right now if
you're a writer can you start using that
skill right now as well as positioning
yourself in a personal brand if you have
knowledge or expertise how can you use
that right now tell me in the comments
below about what you know I've got Malky
plays games your video editor when I
think about especially a YouTube content
creator you know a lot of skills and
maybe you're building those skills how
to design thumbnails
that's graphic design how to edit videos
if you're really good at understanding
marketing and understanding how to take
maybe a long video and cut out snippets
of that video that's something we need
to think media we need somebody who's
like really strong at taking these
longer form trainings chopping them into
smaller videos if you develop that skill
at a world-class level you can leverage
that during this time in this era and so
think about that clarify the skills you
need now sometimes I want you to give
grace because sometimes you go you know
I don't got any skills that's not true
think about the things that you've
learned I just did this this training
the other day in our video ranking
Academy thing and I said what does a
succulent what does this succulent have
to do with YouTube and making money on
YouTube and I said everything if you
look at this little sucker right here
this thing's dying man he's like he's
over hot it's like these things are all
withering
these are dying why because I don't know
how to take care of succulents so what
did I do
I went to youtube and I went to how to
water succulents indoors and and so this
is me the consumer and you need to be
thinking about who you can help who you
can serve right now okay and so I looked
up this video and this video my friends
has six hundred and forty-two thousand
views on it look there's an ad playing
right now cuz this isn't my YouTube red
account and so this succulent Fame
YouTube channel at probably a CPM that's
a little bit higher this video has
probably generated around one thousand
to two thousand five hundred dollars
over the last year succulents how to
water succulents and not kill them so
why is that an issue
cuz I'm over here killing my freakin
succulents that's why I had to buy new
ones and and so every few weeks I just
go to Trader Joe's and I get these for
like six bucks because I'm like what am
I doing wrong but the guilt that I have
I'm like what do I need and check it out
when you start doing this this is why
any skill expertise that you have you
can move it online you can move it on
YouTube you can start positioning
yourself how do I buy that thing do I
need to buy this little water moisture
thing hit me with an affiliate link now
she's not doing that she Bobby beets
should be a part of some of our training
but she should have affiliate links to
like and by the way if you want to get
this little you know measure the
moisture water thing you can grab that
on Amazon we'll shoot I need one of
those I don't want to kill my succulents
anymore I want to keep replacing him and
then later on in the video she talks
about you know this succulent food that
you need to get that's an affiliate link
to man that's that's sold online my
friends this is the opportunity to use
knowledge expertise a skill because I
still need to make my home office
environment dope right now I still need
it I want to keep my succulents alive so
if you're saying oh no I don't got a
skill I don't go knowledge what's your
hobby what's that thing that you know
about you can help guys
me who know nothing about not killing
succulents and 650,000 views on YouTube
answering specific questions so as a
content creator you need to lean in on
this
what is the valuable skill knowledge or
expertise that you can use right now to
make money online but also what skills
do you need to learn right now I think
that the biggest opportunity of being
maybe at a stay at home order is not
right now to watch Tiger king for the
second time come on isn't that the
greatest show you know it's not to to
rewatch the office although that's what
my wife and I are doing right
I saw a meme that said I finished
Netflix what next can you relate you
know video gaming sales record week 1.2
billion video game downloads across
different platforms now I'm not saying
don't play video games I love video
games I I'm catching up on a classic
right now uncharted 4
final fantasy remake at the time of
recording this video drops in four days
and then my business is ruined I mean
every of the advice I'm giving you like
what like what good is it gonna be then
you're not gonna see me all the
livestreams stop Final Fantasy 7 remake
Sean is gone but you get my point like
you gotta rest
you gotta have relaxation you got to
take time off if you're a gamer
well you then you might as well be
gaming cuz you're streaming and that's
your niche but friends we need to reduce
the amount of consumption and up level
the amount of creation but if you are
gonna consume you got to consume content
that's gonna level you up now I know
that you're here on think marketing like
watching this so I am preaching to the
choir but I'm saying like what skill do
you need to learn right now and how are
you methodically intelligently and
strategically developing that skill if
you want to win right now online
you can't just rest on your talents from
yesterday if you've ever seen my first
video it's not good your first videos
would be your worst videos but I've
consistently worked on how do I become a
better communicator how do I become a
better editor how do I master and learn
online marketing how do I learn branding
how do I learn Photoshop and thumbnail
creation now for some of you business
owners
entrepreneurs maybe there's some skills
you want to learn like teamwork and some
of its gonna be delegation but you need
to identify what skill do you need to
learn right now if you're getting value
hit the like button and tell me in the
comments what skill do you know you need
to sharpen and work on right now and you
got to be thinking about the most
important if we're doing strategic
planning for content creators we need to
know shoot I don't know how long this
quarantine is gonna last or they stay at
home order but I'm gonna get so much
smarter and better and prepared for
what's next and even for what's now by
studying learning investing in myself
watching YouTube videos investing in
courses watching webinars and and
turning off the entertainment at a level
and investing in the education that's
actually gonna give me an edge right now
so tell me what skills are you investing
so homeschooler goes public is investing
in audio editing I love it
you know malc mal ka plays games you're
probably gaming a little bit more
because your streamer it sounds like is
doing titles thumbnails descriptions
important learning SEO Elba business
model and marketing critical Sherri's
doing video editing and recording we
need to make a plan what are we doing
we're making a game plan on paper get
out your journal and plan on paper
alright number one first category
what's my shortest path to revenue what
am I going to do because by the way we
also need to be investing in ourselves
during this time we've been looking at
our team I just bought some stuff
tomorrow to level up my skills yesterday
I just bought some stuff tomorrow
I just last night I'm actually in bed
pull out my wallet and I'm like ooh I
got to get that because this is what I
need to learn during this season I've
learned that the best investment you can
make is always in yourself and so I'm
thinking about what can we buy right now
as goods and services we'll probably be
going on discount so look you got to be
wise with your finances but I was
already thinking I was like man this is
a time for the wise investments we need
to make in our business what kind of
gear do we need right now what kind of
education right now what can we invest
in that will be discounted during this
time it's kind of like if you needed to
buy clothes right now which maybe we
don't cuz we're not going outside and
we're not seeing anybody new
every retailer is like forty to fifty
percent off if you're subscribed to any
retailer you know what I mean if you
have resource and you're smart it's
smarter to buy stuff when it's on
discount than it is when it's full price
you know what I mean so as business
owners and marketers being smart about
resources and thinking about how we can
level up and get an edge the second
category is clarify the skills you need
for the future what skill knowledge or
expertise can you actually use right now
even if that's your knowledge of not
killing your succulents you know of how
to water them how to do gardening how to
home-school how to lead virtual team
meetings how to beat you know final
fantasy remake walkthrough game through
it's like whatever there's so many
different things but also what skills do
you need to sharpen we got to come out
of this season sharper than before now
if you want to learn some of the most
critical skills right now again this is
kind of a annex afterparty of the recent
master class we did and I just want to
say if you haven't watched that we're
taking it down in just a little bit if
you go to idea to income dot tips and
it's gone I think it's only up for like
another 24 hours or so but you'll see
either if there's a waitlist or whatever
check out that link in the description
below if you haven't seen it I back in
2015 lost 90% of my income in one
month's time as a freelancer so I got
this major kick in the pants wake-up
call and I actually at the time was like
I have to reinvent myself and pivot now
I was making hundreds of dollars a month
on YouTube in affiliate marketing about
a hundred dollars a month on YouTube
about two to four hundred dollars a
month on Amazon affiliate marketing but
around five hundred dollars a month was
not enough to pay rent living in Irvine
California at the time it was not enough
to take care of my bills so I had to
double down learn and really reinvent
myself and so in this training I did
sure what I did I share my story and
share some of the most important
information about the e-learning
industry about online marketing about
repositioning yourself building a
powerful personal brand on a completely
free masterclass and so definitely check
that out while it's still up and if you
specifically want to sharpen some skills
you're going to love that
training the third area is clarify your
position in the market what does a
content creator do in crisis to prepare
to strategically plan when the future is
so uncertain how do you still
strategically plan you gotta clarify
your position in the market what I mean
by this is your brand and here's what
matters for each and every one of us if
you're a business your brand mater I
don't just mean your business name I
mean your brand what's a brand what do
people think about when they think of
you what do you think about when you
think of Starbucks what do you think
about when you think of McDonald's what
do you think about when you think about
Elon Musk what do you think about when
you think about Bill Gates what do you
think about when you think about Kim
Kardashian people have brands businesses
have brands and people are positioned in
the market when you think about clothing
what do you think about Walmart clothing
versus Nordstrom clothing that's brand
positioning it's both clothes it's two
different positions in the market both
strong brands by the way and two
completely different audiences every
content creator needs to be thinking and
strategically positioning themselves in
the market now for most of us that is
going to mean that we really need to be
thinking about building a powerful
personal brand so listen to this quote
from Dan Schwab all your personal brand
serves as your best protection against
business factors you can't control I
actually really believe that the most
recession-proof positioning to have is a
strong personal brand people I've heard
critics say oh how could you ever say
anything's recession-proof well here's
the thing in any recession and even
depression people are always still
working people are always still getting
clients they're always still making
sales when at the Great Depression
unemployment was not over 30 percent -
my research right we're thinking that
unemployment here in the US might rise
above great depression numbers depending
on how long this lasts but that still
means 70 percent 60 percent of people
are still employed
the question that comes with personal
branding is are you the one who gets cut
or are you the one who's indispensable
and is always in demand this is true for
content creators there's an influencer
marketing there's the top percent that
have strong personal brands trust
loyalty they've built a strong personal
brand so maybe the bottom percent get
cut with this the top still make it also
it's not about being necessarily better
than others it's about positioning
yourself different than others
different is better than better so your
best protection is to be building a
strong personal brand the smartest thing
I did in 2009 was start building my
personal brand
now today that's actually like oh yeah
Shawn it makes sense like it's kind of a
trend like personal branding in 2009 in
my small town Marysville Washington in
our north of Seattle aka cow town is
what my friend Benji Travis calls it and
what it's known for rural I started
building my personal brand and a YouTube
channel and people thought I was a crazy
person turns out 10 years later is one
of the smartest things I could have ever
done fast forward I was a director of
communications 2011 here in Las Vegas
working at a church the CFO named Debbie
she was a friend and she was a little
bit older in her legacy years and she
was saying I was a social media director
and she was like Shawn's social media
doesn't matter social media doesn't pay
our bills at the church social media is
kind of a cool gimmick I think it's kind
of just a vanity metric and she was
actually mocking my efforts not in like
playing fun but she was sincerely like
it's the in-person gathering yell like
she was like that's how she talked she
said yo like there's not not at all
that's like my interpretation
she's like no church is about being
face-to-face it's about gathering with
people agree and that's what it will
continue to be in the future but guess
what you can't do that right now
and right now all these churches and
nonprofits are like shoot we got to
figure out video we got to figure out
live-streaming and if they were not
investing in their social presence as we
move on to an online economy as we move
into a digital economy the way to stand
up and rise above is you have to have a
strong personal brand it's your best
protection against business factors you
can't control and I started building
mine 10 years ago and now I look and
it's like okay so now we are in a
current recession pandemic and a lot of
uncertainty but we've got almost like a
shield of protection because it's work
we did yesterday my friends you need to
plant seeds today for the harvest that
you want to reap tomorrow that means you
need to clarify your position in the
market by building a powerful personal
brand Gary Vaynerchuk says this it's
important to build a personal brand
because it's the only thing you're gonna
have your reputation online and in the
new business world is pretty much the
game so you've got to be a good person
you can't hide anything and more
importantly you've got to be out there
at some level so let me ask you where
are you building your personal brand
with what social media platforms are you
focusing on right now being having a
personal brand is not just I want to
help people in an inspire you also have
to niche down so it's awareness its
specialization it's knowing you're
positioning in the market it's also
getting results in that area so when it
comes to building your personal brand
look when I started in 2009 I had like I
had rhythm had to do I was a video
editor and guess what because of my
personal brand I should have brought
this up in 2009 during the recession my
wife almost dies our economics are
destroyed we're losing our home we don't
know what we're gonna do and then I got
the opportunity because I was discovered
online to move to Las Vegas to work at a
church I was in a church of about 200
people and I got hired no experience
besides just being an intern at a tiny
church to be the director of
communications for a church of 2,500
people and I was sat down in an
interview for the position and they said
why do you think I get you can do this
and I said they go have you ever done it
before and I said nope I've never done
it before but I'll tell you what I have
done I've been building up this YouTube
channel with my friend Jeff Morris
called think international and in 2010
we had a YouTube channel of about 6,000
subscribers 5,000 subscribers and it was
like crazy to them they were like
alright well I think that
let's rock it and so you could see nine
years ago I was building my personal
brand building a brand online building
my skills and we were putting out
content online on this think
international brand it's actually why I
think media is called think media today
and so this was investing back then and
it led so I'm talking about so you could
position yourself out make you know
position yourself make money as a
content creator things like that but it
led to this opportunity of the fact that
I'm looking for where am i I'm in here
somewhere and it led to this here's
here's 2010 Sean right there with the
weird green hue lighting vibe of our
vision video that we shot back then I
was able to in a tough time by the way
people are still hiring right now if you
need what's your shortest path to
revenue if you have a strong personal
brand guess who gets the job the person
with the stronger personal brand so what
do you want to be known for what are
what is how are you uniquely positioned
in the market and where are you building
your influence tell me in the comments
here's a couple other really critical
things to know about this if you're a
Brett if you're not a brand you're a
commodity if you're just another English
teacher if you're just another virtual
assistant this is Robert Kiyosaki right
author of Rich Dad Poor Dad if you're
not a brand you're a commodity like if
you don't have a brand there's just like
Joe's coffee and their Starbucks and
guess what
you are a brand and you need to be
thinking about yourself that way in fact
Tom Peters in Fast Company set it this
way all of us need to understand this is
business owners yo and personal people
you and me all of us need to understand
the importance of branding we are CEOs
of our own companies me Inc to be in
business today our most important job is
to be head marketer of the brand called
you so I'm going to get to these
questions but if we go back to the
shortest path and the fast and then also
the smartest past
making money right now even in the
shortest path your LinkedIn profile like
wherever you're building your up work if
you want to do virtual assistant and do
some work online you got a master social
media marketing and branding right now
like if your son helped me what skills
should I learn those positioning online
branding online marketing because right
now your most important job is to be the
marketer of you and in a stack of
resumes potentially with things getting
very bad like some things may never be
the same again
the whole world's being disrupted here
at think media we're on a mission to
just help you survive and thrive during
this era and so you got to take this
stuff seriously so let's look at some
questions the third area is clarifying
your position in the market so the first
question is what do you want to be known
for what do you want to be known for now
there could be it may be a short term
version of that and a long term version
of that you know I mean I guess I'm kind
of known they think about personal
branding I've done this intentionally
and with also a lot of the resources
that I shared at that idea to income
tips web class but as I've been
positioning a bit kind of in position as
a video guy or the YouTube guy and so
I've kind of become known for YouTube
that's been intentional and by the way
I've wondered at times if you lack
clarity now clarity is a process it
takes persistence it takes grit it takes
patience i abso surely will not get
clarity on one 30-minute or hour-long
session but you got to commit to getting
clear how am i positioning myself in the
market as a content creator different is
better than better so what do you want
to be known for or what do you want to
be known for right now think about this
if you've got a powerful Instagram
account that's just in a specific niche
and you say I want to be known for
teaching English to children and I help
kids learn English in a fast and fun way
that holds their attention and someone
is researching who the teachers are for
doing online tutoring is just
an example and and your branding and
your messaging and they see maybe some
customer Tosa testimonials or they see
some results you've gone then they go
man I want to hire you and then
furthermore if you eventually want to
create an online course or you want
someone to work with you in coaching
which is huge opportunities right now or
even a personal trainer you know they're
looking at your branding and your
messaging but you want to be you got to
be known for something and here's the
thing if you're trying to be known for
10 things you're not gonna be known for
anything like to really stand out in the
market you want to be kind of a master
of one thing and that's a conversation
kind of for another time but that's huge
the second one is who can you help every
content creator needs to answer this
question more than even who can you help
although that is a question who do you
help like who do you help it's who and
what who do you help and what problem do
you solve for them this will help you
right now
so if this if your Instagram doesn't say
this like if your YouTube channel isn't
clear now I know some of you are and you
are you know entertainment but even that
like the same thing I'm helping people
de-stress after work you might not even
put this out in your messaging if you
are clear on this my friend dude for
sure your audience is probably not clear
on this you know what I mean like if
you're like I don't know I'm not sure
well thank god you're here you know like
because as content creators you got to
know who do you help and what problem do
you solve for them one of the reasons
why in the midst of a lot of bad news
there's good news right now is there's a
whole lot of problems in the world right
now people need to reinvent people need
to pivot people need to adapt there's a
lot of problems in the world right now
and we're on a mission to help Purpose
Driven leaders like yourself solve world
problems and we believe that YouTube
live streaming has the ability to do
that you know that mental health here in
America 50% of people have said that
this pandemic has really affected their
mental health and about 30 percent have
said that it's leading to like severe
depression so when it comes to coaching
or motivation helping people deal with
things
when it comes to health and
reinvigorating your health right now
it's real easy to just hit the fridge
multiple times a day cuz you just st.
got nothing else to do learning about
health and mental health physical health
learn about how to have health and your
finances pivot and adapt help people
make money save money help people with
their relationships how do you keep your
kids engaged in home school right now
how do you keep your marriage from
breaking apart and not wanting to kill
your spouse right now you know what I
mean like there's a lot of problems in
the world and problems are opportunities
for entrepreneurs and if you're here and
you're watching this you're a leader
you're an entrepreneur and either if you
have a business you're building a
business who do you help and what
problems do you solve we're building out
our strategic plan this is how you do
strategic planning as a content creator
is we got to get clear on these
questions if you're getting value hit
the like button and let me know if
you're finding these valuable I got one
more for you on this one and where are
you gonna build your authority online
where are you going to build your
authority online you got to know that
and you might be spread too thin if
you're a solo creator you don't want to
spread too thin too soon hey Sean you
know right now dude I'm just like I'm
doing tik-tok like kind of full-time cuz
I got time on my hands plus I'm like a
full-time on YouTube and I know LinkedIn
videos kind of hot so I'm like full-time
on LinkedIn and I know that like
Instagram live and Instagram is really
popular too so I'm trying to like do
that as well but I know Facebook's like
so around so I'm doing that and I know
Pinterest also is a search engine so I'm
kind of trying to rock Pinterest and you
know that's about it but then I'm also
trying to keep my tweets current and
reply to people on Twitter you know if
you're a sole creator stop that's
probably too much have you filmed me you
know what I mean like you got a you got
a really pick your platform and I think
there's something about going deep
here's my advice when it comes to
content creators I think you need to
know your main platform and then a
support platform and that's kind of it
and it takes discipline but I don't
think you can't spread yourself too thin
too soon Shawn you're on like every
platform I have a team they're helping
me here think media and but but Shawn or
you have a team that's
no I built this thing up as a solo
creator just like you have to to y'all
solo creator 2009 to 2015 so I was
hustling for six years I know you're
hustling to I'm just saying I've been
I've been I've been through the seasons
so you got to be smart depending on what
season you're in are you in the side
hustle season are you in the solopreneur
season are you in the scale season I'm
in the scale season if you're in the
solopreneur season you still got to be
smart then for me it was YouTube because
it was the highly elaborate platform
highly esteem I've tried I'd put out
rank videos those rank videos would get
views why I snooze they would compound
and they eventually produced a snowball
of revenue so I could reinvest back in
my business and my team so raising six
fives my main platforms Instagram and a
lot of my traffic comes from Instagram I
like that so let me know about where
your main platform is and where you're
building your authority we know the
importance of building a personal brand
whether you're a business
brick-and-mortar small business or
whether you're just an individual we all
need to be able to build a personal
brand and we also know though that we
got to pick our platform and really go
deep and for you too video is not for
everybody I think video obviously I'm
very passionate about it I think it's
the most dynamic content platform
because it's all of them it really is
writing visual and audio combined but
podcasting is powerful I hope you're
listening to think marketing podcasts
and subscribed here on the think
marketing channel where we have the
podcast new episode drop in tomorrow and
you know you got to pick your platform
and so let us know where your main
platform Allison says YouTube's my main
and instagrams my second I love that and
so really good points and again we'll do
some Q&A coming up in a second but the
third area and we're going through 10
questions that you need to answer right
as a content creator is you got a
clarifier position in the market what do
you wanna be known for who do you want
to help what problem do you solve for
them and where are you gonna build your
authority online hit the like button if
you've been getting value and let's go
into the fourth area
and then I've got some bonus tips after
all of this of course Q&A as well number
four clarify your most important actions
if you're gonna do strategic planning
right now you got to get clear on where
is the most valuable places to be
spending your time you know I think it's
interesting people are like I have so
much more time on my hands I'm like I
don't like like time is so valuable I
choose to invest my time wisely now I
respect that maybe it's learning a new
set of skills but like you shouldn't
have more time on your hands it's the
exact same amount of time we all have 24
hours in a day it's where are we
choosing to invest that time and just
like when you invest money in real
estate it grows over time despite even
ups and downs it grows over time you
need to be thinking about as a content
creator where is the most important
areas of life of business of content
creation that I should be investing my
time right now so I can create here's
what I want you to leave with after this
video is having a strategic game plan to
know what your daily Hustle is to get up
and say I know what I'm doing I know
what I'm focusing on this stay at home
order order might be at the time of
recording this for another month it
might be for another three but I got my
game plan I know what I'm doing I'm
pivoting not panicking I'm gonna pivot
my plan and this is what I'm working on
this is what I'm learning so you need to
be clear on what your most important
actions are first question how can I get
an edge right now how do I get an edge
in this market right now I think a
couple things this is a question though
for you to answer for you think about
this meditate on this later how can you
get an edge in your industry how can you
go you know Wayne Gretsky Gretsky says
you want to skate to where the pucks
going not where it is in hockey right if
you go to where it is you'll miss it
how can get an edge in your industry I
think that education is an edge right
now and thinking about honing and
leveling up your skills the smartest
content creators are gonna choose this
season to get better and not bitter I
also think that massive action is an
edge right now
that I've been stunned by people that
have more influence than we do at think
media more subscribers that have bigger
channels contact creations going crazy
and they're not creating more content or
they're creating less I just want to
call you again
creators create you gotta figure out a
way to get up get motivated punch fear
in the face punch perfectionism in the
face stop worrying about what you can't
control I know it's overwhelming I know
there's a lot happening outside of you
put blinders on don't overdose on
negativity don't have a constant main
line of checking in on stuff you can't
control stay informed please but focus
on what you can control
education is an edge and massive action
is an edge taking massive action so no
it probably shouldn't come as a surprise
we're stretched at think media we
doubled our videos think media went from
like three a week to six a week because
right now we'll shine like why would you
because it's war time y'all this is not
peace time this isn't like oh let's just
chill watch Netflix and ride this thing
out no man you got to know what you're
fighting for and wartime leaders know
what they're fighting for
I'm fighting for my family man I'm
fighting for my team I'm fighting to say
yo if we're gonna keep you on payroll
man we gotta fight and you gotta fight
right now and creators create so so how
can you get an edge right now you got to
define your most important actions I
hope that you're not just taking notes
like writing down these questions but
making notes
what is this inspiring you to do like
what like get your action items shoot I
got to shoot that video I got a plan
that video I got to record that podcast
I can't I got to get up and write in
that book I got to work on that ebook I
got to finish that course I got to apply
for that thing I got to go study you
know up work I'm gonna go see B about
being a virtual assistant I'm gonna go
study that side household video like
create your own curriculum
what do you educate is an edge so so
think about that next question that we
got to ask was we're building out our
strategic plan is how are you gonna
invest your time how are you going to
invest your time right now please if you
you know don't sleep
you don't run your life like lack of
sleep so you got to sleep if you burn
the candle at both ends you'll burn out
and your health matters more than ever
right now you got to keep your immunity
boosted so I'm not prescribing some
toxic level of hustle I'm prescribing
being wise being healthy but it's in a
way it's not even the amount of hours
you work but it's the amount of work you
put in the hours
you can't just scroll on Instagram and
say it's research you can but that
doesn't actually mean you know what I
mean that you're really leaning in you
got to invest your time smart like
minutes matter right now like thinking
about your days thinking about what you
can accomplish in your days and look I
we really want to help you as a contact
crater creators create and it was a lot
of the repetition but like get to get
those videos out like post those videos
because they're gonna build over time
and here's the deal when you're also
investing in learning skilling up but
also creating how much practice can you
put in right now picture looking back
eight months from now twelve months from
now and being like man I put out so many
videos during that time and they were
terrible that's not me that might be the
case they were they were terrible but
I'm so grateful because the 50 videos I
got out in those two months man those
were the learning curve and they gave me
the clarity for what I'm doing in my
business and my brand now I I I started
Messi I took these questions but I
didn't worry about like over analyzing
an analysis paralysis I got a game plan
chicken scratch in my frickin journal
and I got to work in I pressed record
and I invested my time so what are your
most important actions you got to be
thinking about how you're investing your
time answering this your most important
actions you got to define who are you
gonna learn from right now like who
you're gonna learn from to me I'm really
choosing my coaches and my mentors
wisely and I want to make sure that
anyone that I'm learning from yes I want
good information but one of my personal
values is I want to learn from and align
with people who I aligned with their
values I align with their ethics I just
aligned I really believe that your vibe
tracks your tribe as you are helping a
lot of people in our community but also
just being selective about who you're
learning from but that also this is also
just caution about learning from too
many people at one time but I mean I
love so many different people that have
influenced my life but if you listen to
too many people all at once like it's
almost like any strategy is good if you
work it but you can't work 14 different
strategies at once so like a good plan
violently executed is better than a
perfect plan and I got this quote for
you one of my favorite quotes because
this is where I need you to get like
your game plan as we're doing right now
I need you to plan on paper get this
stuff written down but not get into
analysis paralysis George Patton said
this a good plan violently executed now
is better than a perfect plan executed
next week so so you need just like
limited mentors and coaches get a system
get a plan and then work it and I'm all
for like there's been different seasons
where I've like studied different types
of content and whatnot but here's I want
to caution you from following 45
different people ordering 17 books
taking five different courses content
you need it you need a clear plan that's
perfect that's good for you and if you
need help with that too we are of course
always happy to help you can always jump
on the phone with us at talk with think
comm by the way and we would love to
help you there but just who are you
gonna learn from and that might be also
getting clear on what it is you're
actually gonna learn and so we've been
talking about these 10 questions I hope
you wrote them all down if you're just
joining course catch out to catch the
replay but as content creators it's time
to get really clear right now and make
our strategic plan even in the midst of
crisis and I really believe again
there's so much we can't control my
friends there's so much we can we got to
get into that right state know what
we're fighting for know who were
fighting for know our why and remember
that reasons come before results and get
up every day and press record because
content creation is going cray
we shared the stats earlier and so we're
gonna do some Q&A in just a minute the
team has been grabbing some questions
for me but I do want to ask you a
question of the day um
what skill would you identify now do you
need to learn or sharpen right now the
most is it personal branding and
learning about branding in general and
positioning yourself online is it online
business and learning how to grow an
online business and pivot and adapt
right now is it online marketing is it
video editing is it just may be learning
and sharpening a side hustle skill so
you can get your shortest path to income
while you're building your smartest path
to income tell me in the comments below
and then also remember that our free web
class this is kind of the bonus
after-party of that where I wanted to
get you some additional training I go
deep into it's that idea to income tips
link below of course but I go through my
personal pandemic right
I lost 90 percent of my income in one
month was able to reinvent myself and
build a business where I was able to
work from home which is now what most of
us need we need to adapt we need to
innovate I talk about how you can tap
into a three hundred and fifty five
billion dollar industry that's growing
now more than ever and so just don't
miss that write that down circle that
check out that class because it was a
limited time class that we put out with
some very exclusive training and then
also if we aren't connected on Instagram
I'm doing a lot of like daily training
and tips on there on my Instagram
stories and it's also a place where I'm
as active as possible on my DMS and my
direct messages so hit me up at Sean
Kent on Instagram would love to connect
with you and hit the like button if
you've been getting value out of this
video a couple questions have come in
and I definitely want to answer some of
those and I do want to thank you so much
for being here during this training and
so here's the first question from Andrew
is it possible to grow without having to
resort to tutorial videos I know my
niche but I also want to be more than
tutorials basically adventures with some
sort of tips and tricks and so you know
a couple tips that I'm gonna give to you
Andrew
you've submitted a question for coaching
so I'm gonna you know probably not hold
back here and so a couple questions
you know first things I'm gonna
challenge you I don't know what your
circumstances are maybe you're really
business with work busy with work but
you know your your four videos in so I
think you got to just by the way
congrats on starting it looks like maybe
the channel started a month ago I'd also
think dude you're doing great because
150-175 47 you're getting some pretty
good views already
um but obviously you're super early
stage and so remember this Andrew you
kind of got a post around 35 to 55
videos to trigger the YouTube algorithm
if that just made you spit out your you
know ice-t I know it sounds hardcore but
that's just kind of the name of the game
having kind of a clear niche and then
putting out videos is very important at
volume but let me also state this it is
possible to grow with other kinds of
content but the best kind of content to
start with on YouTube is search based
content you don't have to be stuck with
search based content quote-unquote
forever but here's the deal Andrew once
you're known you can do whatever you
want but how do you get known one of the
best ways is to answer specific
questions based off of search based
content researching before you press
record
I hope you've watched our free
masterclass that think master class
where we really talk about that does
that make sense I think that we need to
be disciplined as content creators to
think about yes we're artists yes we
want to do other stuff now hear me it
sounded like the ideas you're sharing or
cool like yeah I try it you're this
you're at a stage where you can
experiment do whatever you want but I'm
just saying it's smart to have a
practical prep path to growth and
awareness first and once you have growth
and awareness like I can drop anything I
want to think media doesn't mean it will
do well but there's at least some people
around to watch it because of the search
based content that I did it first makes
sense and so um sure I think that it's
possible to grow in a lot of ways but
start search space especially on YouTube
and by the way that goes for almost
anything
any platform it's good to be like
Instagram rather than having your
Instagram be cluttered with all kinds of
stuff if it was like all gardening tips
all things gardening all things plants
then people would really want to
subscribe to that because it's one niche
thing that's maybe helping solve a
problem remember who is who is it you
serve and what problem do you solve for
them you want to answer that question as
a content creator across platforms
scorpion 99x says is it ok to stop
posting videos for a while when working
on a big project yeah I think that one
of my mentors chalene johnson says
sometimes you have to slow down to speed
up so if there's some work you need to
do in your business your brand your
personal brand to maybe stop posting
videos for a couple weeks even taking a
month off or whatever to build something
to to position yourself and to get ready
for the next thing then that could be
very wise sometimes you need to slow
down to speed up just make sure you
don't get stuck in what's
procrastination or or really you know
delaying when you're gonna start again
finish whatever project that is and then
get back to it and you could create more
momentum than ever before Steve says I'm
looking to start a positive news channel
similar to the news channel John Chris
Ginn ski just launched any pointers for
such a channel I think that um that's a
good opportunity Steve I don't know if
you've studied Phil DeFranco
I think it's he's a great his his kind
of niche is being as unbiased as
possible and covering both sides almost
all news has some sort of a bias of
course if it's by humans it always will
lean to one side or the other but his
kind of goal is to present both sides he
also focuses on pop culture and things I
think it's a really great idea and I
think it does give you the opportunity
to ride on trends I think it's also you
know I think you know this but it'll
take work and and don't don't give up
too soon I mean when you look at whether
it's mr. beast or PewDiePie or Phil
DeFranco I mean they posted like
hundreds of videos before really
breaking through and it might take a
while to find your your
which level up your skills but I love
the idea and I think it's really smart
and its really needed in the world right
now and so yeah go for it ward do you
differentiate your name versus the
company are running personal brand
versus business brand I do think media
is the You Tube channel company YouTube
channel think marketing this channel hit
subscribe if you're not turned bail on
miss no videos wishes notifications by
the way if you're kind of new to YouTube
and that's a chance to never miss one of
our podcasts or you know one of whatever
and all you got to do is come over here
and click Subscribe although I can't
because I'm actually logged in on the
channel but you got me and you can
either say I want to get some
notifications or I want to see whenever
we post a new video and they're gonna be
you know trainings and podcasts like
this but so those are like brand names
and then I've got my personal brand name
I happen to have a lot of YouTube
channels by the way I do not recommend
that cuz I also have a Sean kennel
YouTube channel that I'm not really
working on right now I want to but I've
got so much going on I think that's
discipline as a content creator just a
word of warning if you're like dude Sean
I got 15 businesses I want to do right
now great right all 15 down Circle one
Sean I got 15 different YouTube channels
awesome write them all down circle one
if you try and chase two rabbits you're
gonna end up catching neither chase one
rabbit catch it
tame it train it with specialized skills
get it working for you train that rabbit
to make money for you get that rabbit
making money like literally the rabbits
like dressed in a tuxedo and like
employed aka the business has some
momentum and then go chase another
rabbit back to your question award yeah
and I think that it's you know there's
Steve Jobs and there's Apple you know
there's Bill Gates and there's Microsoft
Microsoft carries weight in its own name
there's Tesla and there's Elon Musk so
there is you know the ability to build a
personal brand name and a business brand
name I think both are good I think it
has to do with your vision and what
you're trying to retrieve Tricia best
way to learn about SEO and hash tags not
sure how to figure out the best type of
hashtags is that crucial for a video
best way to learn about SEO is think
master class comm and if you want to
check out that YouTube web class but I
do it's 90 minutes long I break that all
down you could check that out for free
and you also learn at the end of it
again a totally free class just at the
end you'll learn about our program video
ranking Academy and whether that's right
for you or not check out the free master
class get a journal take notes and and
then you'll also learn about one of our
programs and that's kind of how we run
here you know we've got advanced
trainings we got a lot of free content
and we're just here to serve and help
and that whatever stage of the journey
you're on we're here to help you with
the next step and so that's at think
master class comm about SEO what I will
tell you what I've learned about hash
tags is how we're using them right now
is for branding I found that from a
search place click-through rate wise or
like people clicking through and
actually ranking quote-unquote for a
hash tag so what we'll do is we'll brand
think media will brand like my name will
bran Omar's name and then it's a way of
organizing so this is kind of cool
because it pulls up a podcast that Omar
was in as well as some of the videos of
course he's created as well as his own
channel so we're using hash tags because
here's my thought is if people click on
them what actually happens on the other
side and so you know when someone clicks
on Sean Cannell I want to you know show
up of course and own my own hash tag
whereas I've noticed that even if you
have like a really good video around
some hash tags the weirdest stuff shows
up on the other side so one person's
advice I think that using them for
branding is really smart and to kind of
organize groups and buckets of your own
content and then we're pop where
possible I think there is a point to
jump on trends and where possible I do
think there are some hashtags worth
going after from a quote unquote ranking
standpoint hey if you've been you know
this is I think the second ever live
stream and the first official live
stream on think marketing so if you're
grateful and you're here hit the like
button thanks for being here and thanks
for it's good to see you Andrew and
Allison and boost leaked media and happy
venture um
next question Jake how did you learn
positioning for me I learned it from my
friend and business mentor chalene
johnson and at on that new web class i
actually talked about a coaching program
that changed my life so if you go to
idea to income tips you're gonna learn
some critical information about
positioning you're gonna learn about a
coaching program that I took that really
taught me basically what it was Jake was
I was building a YouTube channel and I
was having affiliate marketing going but
chalene johnson taught me that there is
really like 15 ingredients of an online
business and I had like three of them so
I was missing foundational marketing
positioning branding critical elements
and we're actually partnering up with
her right now
during this thing if you go to mi a
bonus you can actually see a special
partnership that we're doing with her
with some youtube training that we're
doing in addition to the fact she opens
up her Academy which teaches on that
once a year and it's open right now and
so that's where I learned it now again
if you want to just learn more about
that watch the free class that idea to
income doubt tips
learn and take notes if this is the
right time for you to jump and invest in
something like that great if not great
stay connected to our Channel and that's
a great topic Jake will definitely think
about doubling down on that when we get
back to recording some new think
marketing podcast episodes but chalene
johnson was the go-to person for me on
that as a serial entrepreneur and
someone who holds the world record
holder for the most fitness DVDs ever
sold has built and sold multiple
seven-figure businesses and was really
good at brand new businesses she's
branded diets physical products journals
fitness programs
she had the number one best-selling
infomercial of a fitness program for
Beachbody that she shot on her iPhone
and it actually outperformed a video
they spent over like a hundred thousand
dollars on with all this fancy equipment
because she understands
branding and marketing and so yeah
learning positioning and marketing and
the nuances of that is critical so
that's she's my go-to person raising six
vibes how do you get known on YouTube
when people don't know who you are some
may know you exist but how do you bring
more traffic to your page well answer
the questions on this page but I think
the key is search based content as we
already discovered you know a couple
things I would say is I think you are
known on YouTube obviously you want to
be known more but you really are I mean
you you've got some amazing momentum
here 300 views you know 299 views let me
actually get into my think media account
so that I can see some stats here with
my vid IQ software and so if i refresh
this I think it's always just
acknowledging the growth you are having
and thinking about how you can double
down on that and and so you've got
definitely some really cool momentum
here I think the key to breaking through
is gonna be like specific video ideas
write this down the right title or the
right topic the video on the right topic
with the right title with the right
thumbnail at the right time with the
right content can break you can break
the internet like you are one video away
from changing your life and business and
that's fact I mean again it's not like a
magical promise that that's so easy to
do but when you kind of learn the
process you just keep going after that
and you keep trusting the process to
keep posting videos and then boom you
get that right video at that right time
with that right title and that right and
and that's I mean that's been the
journey of think media we use the
baseball analogy in our video ranking up
academy program where YouTube videos are
sometimes like a base hit and that base
hit might have been like they threw the
pitch you bunted it it was ugly
like just ball kind of falls and you run
your heart out you get on base Bieber
like boo is so cheap so ugly why do you
suck she's like I'm on base it was ugly
it's just like a video you got out there
but when you keep going up and keep
stepping up to the plate and keep
following the best practices and sis
then all the sudden and bam you've got
that home run that if the bases are
loaded that Grand Slam and a rising tide
lifts all ships so then there's
awareness to your other videos so you
know I also want to encourage you it
looks like you've been doing this for a
year but you've really got consistent in
the last two months keep staying
consistent keep leveling up your content
and and then I would again focus on
search based content early on Henry how
do I overcome the discouragement of
being so low I guess that maybe means
being so low as like a solopreneur or
solo creator I mean Henry this is I just
can't tell you what personally worked
for me obviously I think there's a lot
of different advice out there but first
of all it's lonely it's I think it's
acknowledging that it is lonely I mean I
know 2009 our finances are crushed
I searched where I was part-time I'm
waiting tables at Red Robin and I'm
trying to build my business clear vision
media and I don't feel like there's
really people in my corner now I would
say by the way good friends like
hopefully got a community around you for
me that's always been my church family
and and so having people that could just
kind of be around me and encouraged me
just in life in general but in business
at the time I would have like killed
someone to have think marketing like
just for the amount of time I know we
got to connect on Instagram live earlier
there what like live streaming didn't
exist like it did but I mean like nobody
could just go live like this in 2009 you
know there was barely any YouTube
channels like this there wasn't really
any and so I think like you got to get
your network strong so you know stay
engaged with Facebook group so that's
your community side of things I then
think that's this the mindset training
things like strong morning routine if
you've ever heard me recommend the book
miracle morning by how elrod you got to
get up and work on your mindset every
day because you might feel like you're
going at it alone and you very well
could be you've got to keep the vision
so clear that your fears become
irrelevant like you got to have a clear
vision and know what you're fighting for
and I would just yeah sometimes I'd be
like - what the Frick am i editing video
it's Friday night and these videos
aren't even getting views you know why
don't I just go out why don't I just
just just you know escape reality and
just you know just you know check out it
and in and and that wouldn't even
actually be bad I mean it's normal to
like chill on a Friday night but when I
was two solopreneur
I was hustling man and and I had a
vision for what we're doing today and
that vision took over a decade to
materialize but Henry would I would
encourage you is just try to keep that
vision clear even when it gets foggy
keep learning keep growing learning was
a way that I I stayed encouraged because
by feeding my mind with books and online
courses and when I could go to live
events or virtual summits I was getting
around people and I would feed off their
energy and I would constantly get refill
what refueled with tips and strategies
and lastly I'll say this I wasn't just
focusing on you know I think you've
probably noticed we talk we drift into
personal development quite a bit like
we're not talking about marketing
tactics right now but it's my belief
that this is the foundation of the
marketing tactics is is your mindset is
your confidence is being a leader and so
I focus on both and whether that's you
know membership programs of them a part
of or whatever I it was a battle and the
last thing I'd say bro is I just want to
encourage you it's a fight so don't beat
yourself up if you feel lonely that's
normal don't beat yourself up if you
feel like you haven't been getting
results for years I've felt that don't
build yourself up if you question and
doubt yourself daily on is this even
worth it that's all normal but the real
game is sometimes you win sometimes you
learn and if you don't quit you win
Steve Jobs said business is a game of
attrition here's the good news for
everybody watching this most of your
competitors and peers that are starting
right now or even that are ahead of you
are going to quit they're gonna give up
I've seen so many people come and go
over the last ten years maybe if you're
interested let me know in the comments
if you'd want me to talk at greater
depth about my spiritual foundation but
I would also say that that's everything
that is the thing for me I've had to
keep my heart on fire in
my faith and I've had to lean on me on
Jesus you know I'm a Christian and and
my faith isn't I'm not a I'm not a
cultural Christian I'm I'm like in my
Bible and praying and our belief you
know if you're new to Christianity or
whatever is we believe that we can have
a relationship with God and that when we
surrender our life to God that his
Spirit comes and lives inside of us and
that we actually have a supernatural
dimension of our life it's called the
fruit of the Spirit love joy peace
patience kindness goodness gentleness
and self-control or self-discipline so I
hope that maybe it's evident that
there's actually I believe a super
natural element to my life and I'm not
pushing religion on anybody I'm just
sharing what worked for me and that is
that it's a it's this real relationship
that I have built with my Creator and
that I work on and by the way that has
gone through ups and downs and I've gone
through really dark seasons and I've
gone through seasons where I've been
depressed I've gone through seasons
where I've I've like I've not been
pumped about my actions and I've slipped
into habits that are bad and I've gotten
into you know whether that's addictions
or different things like that and I've
had to go through all the seasons man
we're all human we have ups and downs
but like how do you overcome
discouragement that's the game because
if you don't quit you win and so don't
give up bro keep going and I hope some
of that helped if you're getting value
that was a deep place to go but I'm glad
we're here and I hope you're glad you're
here hit like and raising six fives any
tips for kids yoga content in regards to
had a title I hope you're just doing
your keyword research and so I use vid
IQ you need the Pro Plan F to get the
keyword research tool it's just not
included in the free plan that's why I
do a lot of keyword research I hope
you're using ubersuggest as well that's
another one there's a paid plan which
you can do a free version you got to be
doing your research research before you
press record that should be informing
your content excuse me
other tip is I would study what are this
is a power tip y'all what's the most
popular videos in your niche what are
their titles what are their thumbnails
what are they doing in the videos how
long are their videos success leaves
clues and don't be afraid you're not
going to need to copy you're going to be
inspired by some of those titles and
those might trigger some ideas if they
got this many views well then there's
probably a chance for you if you go and
research certain types of titles and the
most popular video has 22 views on it
we're probably you're never gonna get a
very big video around that exact title
or topic chances are so that's the tip
appreciate recruit I've posted over 130
videos and have 16 followers does that
mean my content is rubbish well at some
point you do need to you know think
about when to pivot a recommended
resource for you is called the dip and
so grab the audio book or the physical
book because you know I don't it's it's
sort of a balance of you know the old
saying is is wrong winners do quit and
quitters do win so you know even as I'm
like if you don't quit you win let me be
clear on that even according to the man
Seth Godin it doesn't mean though if you
don't quit the macro hustle that like
I'm gonna make this YouTube thing work
let me be clear I've got like three
successful YouTube channels right now
I've got four failed ones so I have quit
certain niches I've quit certain things
that didn't work I've made Heather and I
Heather tourists hosts of the think
marketing show has we want to do a
podcast episode where we talk about all
our failures and you know you may be new
or our community and you may get this
idea that like man it just looks like
you know what they do works and it seems
to work and win yeah because we failed
so much one of the distinguishing
factors of successful entrepreneurs is
their relationship with failure they're
incredibly comfortable with it
um Thomas Edison was known for failing
10,000 times he didn't think of it as
failure he just learned 10,000 ways that
didn't work until he came up with the
white ball working so that's just a
perspective for you one is that you know
you've learned from these videos I would
hope right and you've been studying
those at the same time though you've got
to maybe say is your niche wrong does
your thumbnail strategy needs to change
does your whole channel idea need to
change does your content format need to
change
check out charisma on command video
influencers rocked my world when he
talked about how you might need to
change your content format if you've
been doing all kinds of talking heads
we're all kinds of teaching videos it
might be time and he explains how they
pivoted their content format so what
does that mean yes I would say that
probably by now it doesn't necessarily
mean your content is rubbish it might
mean that your content needs to pivot
because I think the niche of being you
know helping people with recruiting and
you know in Australia might be a little
niche potentially I think that maybe
there could be support of a blog here
and maybe there's more search on Google
you do have to consider your Tam that's
your total addressable market so one of
the things is this is not a million
subscriber channel it's not even
probably a 50,000 subscriber Channel
you're in a very hyper niche it could be
going moving into a bigger niche we like
to say this wide niche specific videos
and I don't mean lack of having a
specific niche
I mean wide niche meaning maybe you're
like workplace or career development
advice generally and it gives you a lot
more wider topics but yet the specific
thing you actually help with people is
specific videos on the channel but it
gives you more opportunity for growth so
if someone's like I'm only a yoga
4runners channel I'm like I don't know
about that like you might want to be
like a yoga Channel and you have a lot
of Yoga for honor runners videos if that
makes sense
and
so those are a few tips keep going man
in the sense of yeah you might need a
pivot you may need to reinvent yourself
check out the dip by Seth Godin because
that's about it's a tough one because
you also could be right before the
breakthrough you know and and so it's a
matter of figuring out that timing of
really when you should press through the
dip we all go through the lull the
discouragement that this is will I make
it out of this or should I start over
and start something different it's a
hard question and so that's a really
great resource that I'd recommend
Bavarian enthusiasts many of my content
creation challenges are honestly in
between my ears and in my head and I get
in my head and I don't pull the trigger
because I overthink and so if you're
getting like out of this training let me
know hit like if you're getting value
and you know I mostly say if you I hope
you're subscribed to think marketing
podcast check out the episode from this
last week on how to survive and thrive
during crisis I think that's some
important mindset stuff mindset is real
you're obviously saying that and I guess
I could tell you that I had to
strategically intentionally and
repeatedly work on building my
confidence I had to strategically
intentionally and repeatedly work on
rewiring my brain and I mean that it's
called neuroplasticity and our patterns
of thinking how we think are kind of
like highway roads that get so much
traffic on them and ruts get in them I
don't know if you've ever been on like a
road trip you're driving 60 miles per
hour down the highway and all of a
sudden you get into like ruts and it
pulls your wheels because the ruts are
so ingrained in concrete because of cars
repeatedly driving over them and over
them that's how our brains work and the
way we think if we constantly talk
ourselves out of shooting a video or
constantly say I'm so stupid or
constantly say oh you know this can't
work for me or constantly say whatever
they just got luck and like patterns of
thought those patterns of thought
neuroplasticity actually create grooves
in our brain we actually can change
those but it's not a passive activity
and it's actually an intentional what
are you reading what are you listening
to what are you how are you being
intentional with your time
if you're just joining check some of the
questions we answered earlier as content
creators during crisis we need to be
creating our own curriculum and so my
friends I have been methodically
intentionally consistently working on my
heart my mind my soul my confidence my
mindset and growing as a content creator
in the list of skills we need to develop
as a content creator for over a decade
and that's why I mean if you don't quit
you win keep working up and building
your confidence if you're not
intentionally building your confidence
again what you're listening to what
you're reading who you're around and so
there's there's quite a bit it's
probably a topic for another time but
let me just say that man you're in good
company whether it's Heather Taurus
myself whoever you know we all have had
and by the way we still do like it's a
constant battle to work over old
mindsets old patterns of thought and so
don't don't give up you know and and be
intentional about identify what the
thing is that you need to build
confidence in and then go after it if
it's confidence to get on camera go
after it and think about like watching
every video you can about it you know
that's in a program eventually when we
can meet together go to a virtual summit
like I have I've been going to events
reading studying getting around building
my network of the people I'm around and
all of those types of things so I hope
that helps if you're getting value and
you're just joining we're answering your
questions on how you can create a
strategic plan and do strategic planning
as a content creator right now this is
also a bonus session of our recent web
class which the replay is only available
for a short while longer go watch it
right after this or right now idea to
income dot tips link in the description
below I'm gonna share a lot of valuable
training that will help you in this
particular time right now
how do you pivot how do you adapt how do
you move your business online how do you
build your personal brand how do you
market and position yourself you're
gonna love that master class and how do
you type tap into a three hundred and
fifty five billion dollar industry that
is not going down right now is only
growing up so yeah there's a recession
all around us okay yes but there's also
industries that are growing and if you
have the serendipity of this moment to
hear my voice it's time to pivot and you
can do that you might have to learn new
things you will you might have to learn
new skills you will but you can and
think about your future where do you
want to be in the next three years five
years and ten years god forbid but we
know it'll happen five years from now
when something worse than this happens
what are you gonna do today to position
yourself for that well Sean I can only
think about today and getting through
this okay one day at a time but also you
can invest in your future today and your
future reality depends on today's
decisions so anyways you're gonna love
that class idea to income dot tips is
the URL where you can watch the replay
for a limited time check it out a couple
more questions sis Yemi TV Sean should I
start a second channel my current one
has 250k but the content is varied and
scared it stunts the growth should I
separate the content or niche down
that's what we did on thick media that's
why we started on think marketing
channel is to separate some of the
things that are niched I actually can
almost instantly tell the difference
obviously the recipe videos have the
thumbnail that's really consistent I
actually think that there's probably
some wisdom to to that I will also say
that we have done a transition plan even
though we started the new trick channel
we're still kind of transitioning the
content but our goal is that eventually
on think media it's pretty much
predominantly how like cameras and
camera tips like live-streaming gear and
how to livestream with a little bit of
pointing to think marketing for more of
the strategy for more of the how to get
views as well as the build your business
email marketing digital products
learning things on the background and
that's what this channel is all about so
you could maybe start the channel but
transition it slowly but I do think the
key to maybe breaking the channel out is
would really be doubling down on one
type of niche content and I think what
you're feeling in terms of the YouTube
algorithm probably how it you know it
always tells you how your video
performed according to the last ten and
it's telling you because
les subscriber interest you want to
follow those cues and here is the video
to watch check out video influencers
Laura Vitali and it's it's I think it'll
really help with the clarity that they
had for their YouTube channel this is
the video pursuing your passion with
YouTube you're in cooking as well and so
is she so I think you're gonna love this
video so definitely watch that at a
later time as well Casey what's the best
platform right now to put out content
for churches I've been wanting to do
training and personal development for
worship for a long time but it seems
like the perfect moment Casey I think
that YouTube is still the best for
evergreen content YouTube is the only
platform where your content lives
forever it's search based churches are
trying to learn how to do those types of
things so I would definitely do it
they're saying that I think that where
they're they're the most active is on
Facebook and Instagram so I don't know
if that means you you you do both in the
sense of not that you really fight the
war on two fronts but maybe you don't
get so passionate about forcing them to
come to YouTube you do want to go to
where they are it could mean doing a
Facebook watch channel meaning Facebook
videos on a fan page because a lot of
church leaders are over there and of
course they're on Instagram as well so
you know kind of an interesting question
let me kick it back to you and maybe
even think about the people in your
network like what churches are you
connected to what denomination call a
few get a vibe on a few where you
consuming content what do you want to
learn I'm serious like get on the phone
with them and and then ask yourself
where are they cuz that's the best
question where is the target audience
that you're trying to reach LinkedIn
video right now is hot if your target
audience is there and there's more
organic reach than almost anywhere else
and so but it doesn't mean that if
you're trying to reach fourteen-year-old
girls you should go there tik-tok on the
other cases where you should go tik-tok
is there's some you know strategies I
think to also get in front of people but
I think there's probably the multi front
channel if you've got a lot of time on
your hands you got to go all-in on grind
and I think I know I recommend really
staying focused on one platform but the
last thing I would say this I think will
add value
is there's something about YouTube being
the place where your pillar content
lives where you're like main evergreen
weekly video show lives and then we're
micro pieces of that can go everywhere
else so even as a solo creator there's
something about maybe having like your
weekly Tuesday show that serves your
target audience who are you trying to
serve and what problem do you solve for
them and then by chopping that up and
maybe going live on Instagram and other
places and then adding value answering
questions
connecting DMing with people and
educating about this weekly pillar of
content that lives on YouTube I think
that's what I would do is if I was you
because I would want to build again I
think YouTube is the best long-term best
real estate to invest in yes it's hard
to grow here yes it can take time yes
but it is the most valuable in my
opinion platform to have broken through
on and it's like a well that once you've
dug continues to quench your thirst and
help you make an impact for like weeks
months years to come so citizens that is
Sean how do I break into the algorithm
speaking about current events vlogging 3
weeks and 22 videos in well you know
remember 35 to 55 videos is is the key
to even hitting the algorithm secondly I
think it's actually kind of getting
really clear I don't know if you could
break through with this kind of content
now sure if you're super funny
you do the right viral video at the
right time and that's possible but I'm
much more of a practical person and so
while I think some kind of vlogging is
clear you know even the idea of vlogs my
question is like who does this help and
how does it help them the goldfish rule
Microsoft did a study found that a
goldfish is attention span is 7 seconds
then they did a study and found that
because of the internet and social media
and phones and so much distraction that
now humans attention spans are 6 seconds
so that means your attention span of my
attention span is shorter than a
goldfish tell your boyfriend that your
girlfriend that right you know what I
mean
like see how they feel and so they're
like that's true never pay attention to
me when I talk and so I don't know what
this is like what is this gonna do for
me how is this gonna help for me is it
humor what's the promise
where's what am I get it so if I come
here which I'm not going to because by
the way why was my point in the goldfish
story I got six seconds land here look
at it even if I read sorry not sorry
sincerely your what does that mean kovat
road trip I don't know you why do I want
to go a road trip with you parenting in
place I'm sorry I'm being hardcore but
you know we're coaching right I'm trying
to help you I think you could really
pivot cruising through quarantine so if
YouTube's a search engine
I mean how to make your own hand
sanitizer is is the most practical video
on here and I think that when we look at
some of these topics even these you know
like I think that it's it's definitely
maybe a retooling of your strategy re
going through the ten questions we asked
in this training and I also think it's
it's it's checking out the idea to
income tips training I mean it's a lot
there's actually there's quite a bit of
work to do here now let me give you the
good news
you've got momentum I can see you're
creating videos you're already creating
you're already on camera you've already
got some stuff out and you've already
already got some views and stuff can I
be honest this kind of reminds me of my
channel Sean kennel when I started and
the reason I bring that up is again I
eventually pivoted because of even
advice like you're getting right now I
sort of learned I was like where is this
really even going like how's this who's
this help who's this for
is this a proven niche what's the
competition like so I was shooting
videos freestyle Eminem verse Lady Gaga
at Red Robin you know I should play that
video sometime for you it's pretty funny
and and you know random online dance
parties and Tom's like just going live
and just upload and eventually vlogs and
eventually an amazing spider-man review
and you know just random stuff and
here's the point I mean I got some views
I even had some breakout videos
but it didn't work you know but this was
all learning for me and then I pivoted
and really got clear on am I in a strong
niche am I in my strengths have
identified a clear target audience Who
am I gonna help and what problem do I
solve and then have I mastered my
branding my marketing around that so my
channel is clear clarity is power
clarity cuts through the noise and then
if I figured out how I'm gonna be
different so yes you might even but
here's the problem even if you had a
breakout video I don't even know if what
do we lead to next so I think right now
it's less about gaming the algorithm or
you know you know hacking the algorithm
it's more about getting clear on what is
it you're building where is it going
what's it gonna look like what do you
want your brain in business to look like
in years from now how would you know if
you won you know is it just and and if
you it's like well I just kind of want
to be famous and be like a famous like a
vlogger like somebody else all right
well great and that might be a similar
level clarity but it also might not be
that practical because here's what I'm
excited about I think that taking a
practical and strategic path on YouTube
opens up a lot of opportunity for
hundreds of thousands of people hundreds
of thousands of people are making a
full-time living or at least a
five-figure
meaning $10,000 or above income off of
YouTube and that could be done because
of practical channels and specific
niches serving a specific audience
it is the fraction of a percent that
kind of just if you will blow up and get
famous or whatever so just trying to
spit my truth and take it for what it's
worth and I do appreciate you for being
here and I hope that advice helped if
you're getting like hit the like button
if you're getting like I'm getting the
delirious I don't know how much longer I
could go y'all I filled in my voice I
forget value can you show some
appreciation and hit the like button can
you turn on notifications for all you
speakers out there youtubers that get a
dry throat or a hoarse voice can I
recommend a product for you
entertainer secret throat relief my
friend Pat Flynn promoted this link
below twenty-two ninety-five and he I'm
just kidding but it is a highly
recommended
oh yeah I'm ready to grind now giallo
Matos what's the when is it the
appropriate time to approach brands with
affiliate to try to get them to sponsor
your videos I think that there's not
really a size to it I think that it's
theirs it has you want some momentum you
want to clear a niche and you want to
just have like a clear pitch on why they
should work with you and who your
audience is so I think I've had their
tourists come on you know or if you're
part of think marketing community the
host of the think marketing podcast
she's got her homeschool channel now
it's definitely a side side side side
project for her because if we check this
out you know she has not uploaded a
video in quite a while but yet her
channel has still grown by 400
subscribers in the last month and almost
20,000 views in the last month crazy
right well that's the power of ranked
videos we teach about that on our free
masterclass that think masterclass calm
but she has had the opportunity to get
like sixteen hundred dollars worth of
homeschool curriculum for free from a
curriculum company she's had the
opportunity to get featured in
homeschool blogs and homeschool like
she's done affiliate marketing I think
she's done other brand deals because and
and she's got 15,000 subscribers now and
again growing every single month and
this is here's the power here personal
branding power having a specific niche
power digging your well on YouTube
throughout the seasons this is not going
away friends so it's a busy season right
now we're going all-in on think
marketing and think media she not only
is still adding value and DMing home
school moms and helping people but like
think media is ten years old
like this will be a hundred thousand
subscriber channel like this will be
it's it's just patience in the game
right and when you have videos that get
you views 24/7 365 like her videos um
that are really value based that really
helps so she got I think her first if
you will brand deal sponsorship at just
a few thousand subscribers so you do
need some
some views but I think the key though is
those people that have wanted to work
with her wanted to work with her because
it wasn't about the size of her audience
it was about the quality of her audience
and how specific they were now if you
want just big numbers you might be doing
like pranks and it's like I you need
millions of views for like some app that
everybody would install but I think the
real power is getting clear on a niche
and then it doesn't matter if your
audience is small brands will want to
work with it because all the people that
are subscribed like it's home school
moms you know I mean like this isn't
like my jam this is not my channel but
they are like okay shoot if you can you
know talk to on your most recent video
2000 moms that want a home school we
want to get in front of that audience is
that making sense and so shout out to
Heather and shout out to new think
marketing episode's coming soon but
that's the advice that I would give you
Cajun cooking I got a 12 year old recipe
site 4 million views 6600 subscribers
but we've not kept it up only getting
about 275 views the days worth reviving
yeah because it's still seen in
YouTube's eyes with with old videos I
think I might rebrand it a little bit
but more than anything I would just
start posting new videos it might take
you a while to get it going I do see
you've got some videos going but but
even based on what I'm seeing here I
would I would actually say look at this
you're getting 7000 views a month
this is vid IQ by the way and you know
30 new subscribers a month so dare I say
you know it's not even it doesn't even
need to be revived my friends this is
alive this looks like a heartbeat
doesn't it beep beep beep beep it's
another that's in the hospital room this
is not a flatline channel this is great
be encouraged and double down and like
start leveling up and going all in on it
on and here's what I think your biggest
opportunity is if you want to double
your views double your videos so I don't
know what your circumstances are right
now but I'd love to see at least four
four right here tells me one a week but
I'd like to see eight here
keep the quality as high as possible
solving problems you know and so this is
looking great and yeah I'd be thinking
about how you can evolve an update but
congrats and what a blessing that's I
think the blessing of work you've done
yesterday there's life it's awesome you
know what I mean again if you want to
give us flatlined is a lot of life
they're just trying to like wake that
back up the alternative is my gosh like
you go in subscribers eight thousand
humans watched your content in the last
30 days really being grateful for where
you are while you're leveling up for the
future farmhouse teas what advice would
you give a company using youtube to sell
a product we have a mix of tutorials and
blogs our popular videos don't
necessarily have to do with what we sell
that's the game I think that what you
want to do is just add value get to know
people build a tribe as you're doing and
then educate as it seems you're doing
throughout they're integrating content
into your videos but also doing what it
seems like as just like a dedicated
video that looks like it's related to
your products and by the way I love
kombucha and this looks great and super
fascinating to me and I just want to
drink kombucha right now but yeah this
looks so I mean I think you are doing it
it looks like you're also doing it in a
way where I think people would probably
have a really good vibe about it like
because I could you just you know if I
could just open and and and and you know
adding value you got ebooks so I love
that you got the online biz side of
things going and you're kind of building
and scaling that kind of stuff so I
think it's just doubling down the
strategy I'd recommend is um it's by
thinking about like what would be some
of the biggest video opportunities and
breakout video ideas in your niche so
like researching underneath your promise
who you help how you help them so people
that are interested in tea what are some
of the biggest tea videos what are some
of the and we called them as you have
done here adjacent topics there's your
main thing your main product the main
thing you sell but then there's also the
adjacent topics that your target
audience the person you help is also
interested in like someone who's
interested in kombucha is probably like
ultra ultra also interested in other
natural living naturopathic remedies you
get that right and then it's just
thinking about remembering your one
video away from changing your life and
business first of all being super
grateful for the fact that you're
getting thirteen thousand views a month
growing by 190 subscribers so that's
epic two video uploads can we do double
your videos you can double your views
especially related to maybe not that
number right but you could double like
if you're getting you know at least 200
views a video well then two videos would
be 400 views but four videos will be 800
. just from simply increasing the volume
and can you do that right now i call you
back to the 10 questions calendar block
your most important actions especially
right now creators create friends we got
to double down on content but we want to
be creating smart content research
before you press record you may have
seen our class on that definitely check
that out um and and thinking about
researching trends some people
misunderstand me when I say trends I
don't mean like researching trends that
are unrelated like o Marvel Captain
Planet is like Captain Planet remember
him that's not Marvel but Captain Planet
he's a hero huh gonna take pollution
down to zero he's a hero I didn't think
we were gonna go there but this is how
delirious I'm getting hit the like
button if you're having fun Captain
Planet in the house trends in your
industry again the right video topic
with the right title with the right
thumbnail posted at the right time
Google Trends can't really talk about
that right now cuz the time but you know
thinking about some of those strategic
videos can be a game changer for you get
lipid fishing is research before
recording the best way to break through
in a saturated niche really rapid fire
because we've touched on that
goto idea to income tips for more advice
on how to break through in a saturated
niche about web class while it's so
available the best way to break through
in a saturated niche is being different
different is better than better and
there's a book to check out it's called
the blue ocean strategy again you're not
trying to be better if you were in like
filmmaking let's say be rolling stuff
you're not trying to be better than
Casey Neistat or better than Peter
McKinnon and you're trying to be
different and a lot of people in like
the youtuber space are just trying to be
them they're that is already taken you
know what I mean don't try to be
somebody else you got to be you times
two and figure out how you're different
and your background your ethnicity your
style your age those are actually all
assets because your vibe attracts your
tribe so when you double down on who you
are and in your unique niche then you
can really stand out so blue ocean is
good to look at and the analogy I think
about is this you know again let me know
if you drink coffee shout me out are you
a coffee drinker tell me in the comments
right now let me know how much coffee
you drink per day and let me know if you
have a coffee curfew mine is typically 2
p.m. and when I break that I know that
we've really been grinding right and so
you know I see you here I spend a ton of
time on edits because my channel is
known for high quality edits and it
takes longer should I start spending
less
I do think you got to balance that
sometimes you got to put out some sevens
sometimes you want to put out more hero
videos but remember it's about content
value not production value yes
come on yes three cups of coffee a day
apprentice recruit I love it and gently
Laura I missed the book name it's called
the blue ocean strategy you'd probably
be good enough reading the summary but
it does talk about how companies
position themselves a blue ocean is
different is better than better because
when everyone's doing the same thing
you're competing with somebody who's
already doing it when you reposition
yourself and here's the thing it's not
necessarily to do something different
watch this I help like I help people
overcome negative thinking
and betta anxiety okay but so does a lot
of people and and from a personal
branding standpoint what you do is
pretty clear but it specifically who you
help is not that clear and niche down
imagine if you said this I help single
millennial moms develop a winning
mindset and overcome anxiety and build
confidence
uj-- your blue ocean could be the group
of people you're reaching even though
the content is the same as everybody
quote-unquote like a lot of people are
doing it there's a lot of levels of
distinction in which you can be thinking
about who it is that you ultimately help
so the book's call blue ocean but if you
think about um the blue ocean strategy a
lot of you drink coffee Cody doesn't
oh he's joking though the Cody coffee
business
I got it man clever eight cups and
anybody can anybody beat Anthony I hope
I said your name right can you buddy
beat him anybody drink more than eight
cups a day so a lot of people drinks
coffee here's a question do we need any
more coffee places in the world there's
a probably already too many I grew up in
Seattle and when I was growing up I was
there for the genesis of Starbucks but
here's the deal a lot of the world
drinks coffee huge market but there was
McDonald's coffee already
Pete's coffee Seattle's Best Coffee
Dunkin Donuts coffee there was local
espresso stands local coffee shops so
who in the world would want to start a
new coffee shop well Starbucks launched
the first ever their first store didn't
even sell coffee just sold beans that
you take home is just a roastery and
then this second a second store went
Pike Place Market downtown Seattle but
they launched a coffee company that you
probably have heard of if you've heard
of Starbucks before and they now are
like the biggest or one of the biggest
brands in the world stores everywhere
and known look they're coffees not even
that good in my opinion it's not my
preferred place of coffee yet I still go
there because it's convenient because
it's consistent but they created all
kinds of new distinctions the third
place free Wi-Fi coming
out here we want you to hang out here
now they got all kinds other things
snacks other things they'll sell you and
they kind of became the McDonald's of
coffee it's always the same it's
consistent it's repetitive here's the
thing coffee was crowded at the time and
still is yet they built a brand because
they didn't try to be McDonald's that
was a certain vibe they didn't try to be
Dunkin Donuts that's not the same as
Starbucks nor did they try to be my
preferred coffee place because I'm kind
of a hipster I'm gonna try to go to
battle over here and I'm gonna try to
get some like Kenya pour over let it
bloom get the thing going I want some
floral notes some citrus in there okay
I'm a little bit of a coffee snob
I want that niche if I go into a coffee
shop and the barista doesn't have like a
waxed moustache with tattoos and like
you know super hipster like some pierced
ears and like you know just wearing some
like vans skate shoes that's not my spot
I'm like this is not the right place if
this guy's wearing a uniform I need to
see that like man bun freakin pour-over
Aeropress competition level of coffee so
it's all coffee hipster coffee shop
Dunkin Donuts Starbucks same thing as
coffee you might feel like it's to cut
too much competition out there friend
but here's the thing you got to just
figure out your positioning different is
better than better
where are you positioned in the market
it's not that you're doing something
different in the sense of you might be
teaching YouTube tips to like me you
might be teaching them to different
people that have a different learning
speed they might just connect with you
because your vibes different than mine
and you're not they're not as
caffeinated or not as caffeinated as me
or as crazy whatever does that make
sense it's all coffee but it's different
positioning and if you want more that's
why I believe that as we sharpen our
skills right now that we need to double
down on learning branding personal
branding marketing market positioning to
really build a distinct online business
because I'm not trying to say it's
to be easy I am trying to tell you that
it's worth it and that yes you can break
out and I'm also saying that you might
be like okay well just tell me what it
is this clarity journey can take time
and it takes investing time and
resources and and and sitting down and
not just like watching content like this
we're not just investing in a coaching
program or an online course doing the
work and clarity took me dare I say
months years I mean and I think I could
have shortened my learning curve if I
had things like think marketing and
things like some of the the resources we
share with you again the right books or
whatever but it's still gonna take time
we believe in our commitment to you at
our company is we believe we can shorten
your learning curve by seventy five
percent 100 percent we believe that what
does that mean if this took me a decade
it's still gonna take you two and a half
years just trying to be real talk this
is not some get-rich-quick Channel this
is not some magic pill magic weight-loss
take this pill lose 15 pounds and have a
shredded six-pack in the morning you
know and I know that that doesn't exist
but what does exist is predictable
success through leveling up your skills
positioning yourself right repositioning
yourself in the market start a new
channel doubling down in your channel
pivoting your channel this stuff matters
and that was the theme of today's
content strategic planning if you're
just joining check out the replay and
get all 10 questions and here's your
next step I hope you've been journaling
and taking notes I hope you've been
writing these things down and I hope
that now you can put them into practice
and go work on your plan if you haven't
watched the master class that we did or
the web class it's only available for a
little while so maybe you want to watch
that next idea to income dot tips it's
gonna help you plan to pivot right now
in the current economy and not just this
economy but where the future is going
and never turning back we are not going
backwards from live video video online
marketing and building online businesses
brick and mortar and physical businesses
might never be the same and many won't
but online is what is happening no
matter what and if you have a brick and
mortar business or some sort of a
physical business that will return
you better also have your online
strategy in place and there's never been
a better time to dial that in than right
now
and so thanks so much for being here on
this training and hey if we're not
connected on Instagram let's connect
there and smash like if you got value
out of this video and also if you're
just watching this on youtube and you
want to check out a video next check out
this video on how to make money with a
small Channel and right now it's never
been a better time to be investing in
YouTube creators create right so click
or tap the screen to watch that video
it's one of the episodes of the think
marketing show make sure you subscribe
for future episodes and we'll see you in
the next one just click or tap the
screen to watch this video how do you
make money with a small channel I'm
excited about this because I have a
small channel mine's only at almost
15,000 subscribers and we have a lot of
people who look at you with 1.5 million
subscribers having a 7-figure media
company all these big things